this
is all that's left of the bus after the
powerful explosion in a kabul suburb
the bus was carrying soldiers home when
the suicide bomber struck
hardly a day goes by when the afghan
capital is spared attack
just hours earlier at least 12 soldiers
were shot dead by taliban gunmen
while they were working to clear mines
in helmand province
the violence came on the same day that
germany's defense minister ozola
fondelion
made an unannounced visit to the
bundesberg's base in mazari sharif
the bundeswehr mission with the most
casualties in the german military's
post-war history
ends in three weeks
fund alliance said germany owed it to
the victims to continue helping afghan
forces boost their security capabilities
the taliban will stop at nothing to
destabilize the fragile new government
in this transitional phase
that means it's all the more important
for us to stand alongside afghan
security forces and help them
counter this threat afghanistan
about 850 german troops are set to
remain in afghanistan
to help train and advise afghan soldiers
as part of what's being called mission
resolute support